[music]
me
Even if you're a hotel kid who usually dies
I shouldn't know
Boohoo good good
me rar n
[music]
tan
eh
Prahe mode zubo
Stop and goo
alle
I'm not going home
Giants party number 1 no
Issuing the eight-sword style ice sculpture Only the oboe
moves
upwards  I held it It
was a sunny day
I thought it was a frog Yes,
Ino Goon
You are
0 hot water
p Eh,
I can still be strong
Ah ah ah
I can say in autumn and winter It's
easy, but Pooh who shows silliness here too
Huh
[applause]
[music]
I've only fallen in love with that language yeah yeah yeah yeah
You should have run away when you realized you could
n't stand up to
me
I've already been in the hot water, Luger
[music]
My name is manana
What's new?
Naval Headquarters Colonel Rado Southern on the far right
You can cut me in half and stop me
me Let's calculate
your l Color beyond that
Takuhicho
heavy machinery
ran
[music]
Sakura Miki
can't move forward It
's different if it starts moving
Power up
ah ah ah
[applause]
[music]
no
[applause]
goo
ah ah